[Music]
who's going first
so shout out by the way to uh to pod boy
who's been posting these
so first off but until pod boy's been
posting these and these are he's been
posting older episodes of Bobby Lee when
less people watched him it's padman pop
fair enough by the way always respect
the Zoolander reference um
black long pump this is from tigerbelly
2019.
this we learned some valuable
information here uh Bobby has relapsed
on meth and alcohol and kalila is taking
advantage of the situation rather than
getting Bobby the help he needs Bobby
was addicted to meth
did you know that
I don't know
because Island needs Bobby to do the
podcast that's all here's another thing
okay so this is
bro what you're about to hear is [ __ ]
wild that's going on with me
if you don't mind yeah
um
I told you guys earlier that Eric
Griffin and my brother called kalilong
last week and saying that I'm having a
nervous breakdown that I should
be put away or something that's not what
they said what did they say
that you should be confined in 5150
what do they say coming from a 5150
three Peter me she's been 51.50 three
times now let's explain what 5150 is for
not everyone there 5150 is a California
version of The Baker Act we have it here
but for the most part every state has
something involuntary 72-hour
psychiatrist holds where if you start if
you start doing something that looks
like you're danger to yourself or
somebody else every State's different
but I could tell you Florida because I
know Florida in Florida you need to have
a family member and a third party
be like okay yeah this person you know
72 hours are danger to themselves that's
basically the Looney Bin lockup that 30
for the most part Most states are 72
hours if you're a different state tell
me the name of yours 5150s is
Californians uh so she has been
involuntarily locked up three times so
you're telling me the woman who jerked
off dogs and [ __ ] not one but two of
her brothers was locked up three times
for being crazy
get out of town
no seriously leave no seriously get out
of America yeah
um that's absolutely not what you need
and that's not what they said what did
they say they said they basically echoed
my sentiments about you which I told you
privately three weeks ago is that I
think that you're going through a manic
phase
women do this and it's not just her but
she's really bad at this
they're not medical professionals
they're not psychiatrists they're not
therapists but they immediately women
nobody loves to misdiagnose somebody
more than women do they you see it all
the time right immediately because
somebody once called her manic now
everybody who does something that annoys
her is also manic yeah or bipolar I
learned a new diagnosis now I'm going to
diagnose everyone at minorly
inconveniences me or the female n-word
narcissist
I think that your thoughts are scrambled
I think that your actions are very
erratic manipulative
insane woman yeah and I didn't tell your
brother that because I was hoping maybe
someone maybe it was my perception that
was fooling me by the way shout out to
pod boy for pointing this out pushing
multiple narratives to distance herself
from any accountability
and when he finally told me and said hey
this is what I've been noticing I was
like oh thank God then I can finally
you know we can finally all talk about
it and in case you don't believe me
because like my words not everything
Marsh you you you're pretty good at the
women like this and I think I'm pretty
good at this like
she is doing the
she's a peach manipulative manipulation
101 is what I would call what she's
doing right everything she's if you
wrote a book about how to manipulate
somebody yeah she's manipulating Bobby
she's manipulating his friend and his
brother too and the audience and the
audience she's manipulating everybody
it's just my perception
but I think you're manic but then see
they take accountability out of it by
saying but hey what do I know
you know the whole like hey what do I
know in case in case it's [ __ ] up you
don't want to be blamed for it you know
oh I don't know do you want to talk it
really is the ultimate out right you're
like you know I'm just sticking your
Manic and uh narcissistic mental issues
well you know what do I know ah you know
what I know okay but like you were very
specific I think you're spiraling in
your decision making lately has been
crazy okay saying a lot of crazy [ __ ]
okay
what I know it seemed like you knew very
well a couple sentences your brother too
and your friend is also wait other
people are talking about me well I've
been getting I've been planting it in
their heads but yeah
what do I know
that's why I'm that's why I brought it
up but I made an appointment for you see
your you have your very first in your
life therapy sessions
she's the one that got Bobby into
therapy oh yeah you didn't know that oh
yeah that was everything he's done in
the last few years because of her
I didn't know I honestly didn't know she
was the one that got him into it I
thought that's something that just all
these La Comics do you know tomorrow
which are generically like you know or
not generically but multiple showing up
yeah they all go to therapy because some
crazy gold digging [ __ ] lunatic [ __ ]
gets them into therapy after they
alienate them from their family and
anybody that actually gives a [ __ ] about
them oh that's fair
what's up two okay yeah I'm going
and I'm so glad that you are going yeah
I just don't feel like I'm Kanye I'm
gonna go to an Apple store and do rap on
one of the tables you never know I've
done it you think that I'm a sane person
now no I don't think you've ever been a
sane person I think that you you you put
out because I was thinking about this
the other day kalila puts out some crazy
things like jerking off dogs and [ __ ]
her brothers and stuff that she said by
the way she says these crazy things like
that I think in a way to Shield her from
the horrible manipulations that she does
because now she's going like oh my God
even though I'm controlling and telling
what to do I'm also crazy
what have you done I've the reason I was
51.53 [ __ ] times in my life is
because I lost my mind I had a nervous
break you didn't lost your mind you know
who lost her mind licks
ah you have schizophrenia yeah licks I
would believe I would believe you
and your actions um sometimes are very
pure and full of love oh wow it really
does look like he's on something in this
huh
yeah he sounds like it too yeah this is
a difference like himself yeah yeah yeah
somebody's reactions still are
diabolical and diabolical aggressive and
violent so she said that sometimes the
stuff you do is diabolical aggressive
and violent and he stayed with her for
another three years and I want to say
something to you guys he still lives
with her
I think he just moved out I mean this is
within a couple days ago I didn't play
it because it's I don't I'm not 100 sure
but that's what I heard anything
I was gonna let it go maybe write a book
about it later or
um do something but
what
wow he is broken and it's dude she took
this is worse if you really think about
it she took she just take advantage of
like a low self-esteem Bobby Lee because
Bobby has a little something to see me
always says it but
he took advantage of a drug addled
you know what I mean a drug adult losing
his mind Bobby Lee so she just preyed on
him she and then she cooked or crooked
her claws in him so that way she could
ride her look the only reason she's on a
show is because is because she [ __ ]
Bobby Lee This Woman's not a comic you
know it's not like this woman is a
comedian or an actress or anything just
[ __ ] her way into the group of friends
this is one of those where a lot of
people say that and you go that's not
fair she's actually pretty funny some
people you know they say that but
they're fine but but she's not funny
she's not the funniest person on any one
of her own shows she's only the most
interesting person because she's because
she's [ __ ] insane
uh uh what happened what did I do did I
you broke it you broke the internet
people kept saying something that
everyone's been promising for years so
he's gonna break the internet and Royce
finally did it
she tried to kill me there today whoa
whoa whoa
sorry sorry what that escalated very
quickly
yeah
I would believe I would believe you
and your actions um he's doing this a
lot you know what I said
yeah sometimes are very pure and full of
love
some of your actions some are diabolical
and
diabolical aggressive and violent
and I want to say something to you guys
and I wasn't going to say anything
I was gonna let it go maybe write a book
about it later or um do something but
she tried to kill me there today oh my
God you know what he's talking about
[ __ ] Liars he knows what you're
talking about oh no no no no she doesn't
know you should be a politician
the amount of people that you influence
with your lives is really really
staggering that's you
the amount of people you influence with
your you that's you I a hundred percent
believe that she tried to kill
I honestly after everything
5150 three times
I says this
she needed me in the jaw so she she
takes my head she leaves me in the jaw I
open my mouth and Blood starts oozing
why did she need him
what happens with your lies is really
really staggering can I say so it's this
she needed me in the jaw so she she
takes my head she leaves me in the jaw I
open my mouth and Blood starts oozing I
admit it was pouring out of your mouth I
had blood losing out of my mouth
I couldn't talk and my mouth opened my
mouth it's blood okay and the sides of
my mouth there's these two gigantic
holes
can I show you guys the video there's a
video I'm Gonna Let You
giggly it's not premeditated so this is
what he does anytime I turn because
we're filming stuff for Bobby right now
right so my camera is always on
and when the camera is on he he himself
turns on so what he wanted to do was
um pin me down and tickle me
and which was a really grave mistake
because he pinned he tried to go for a
single leg he got my leg pinned it down
put my foot right to his face like
pinned it down to his chest and face I
instinctively retracted and pulled my
leg upwards she did it on purpose 100
she's lying she did it on purpose
because she doesn't like explaining it
she doesn't like to be tickled and she
told Bobby not to do it anymore and he
did it because he's being you know we
[ __ ] we're out guys we're [ __ ]
and
um she did it on purpose the exactly
Mercer right she is over explaining like
whenever you know somebody's guilty like
in the first 48 or whatever you see the
interrogation and they kept to keep
talking too much
he closed his jaw in his own tongue oh
that's crazy and so I I and then I
freaked out because I heard the noise I
was like
and then he rolls over the side of the
bed and he opens his mouth and he's just
pouring blood Gilbert imagine two kids
tickling each other you bet your own
tongue how does that mean okay got it
you're the is your knee
imagine two kids tickling each other
having a good time having a great time
yeah giggling yeah like kids right and
all of a sudden one of the kids right
pulls out a gun and kills the other kids
that's exactly what out of nowhere she's
angry look at her body language she is
angry she's angry because this story
started with her throwing Bobby under
the bus and saying that he was Manic and
he needs help and and this is an
intervention and then it turned on her
and the moment any heat you put on Earth
she falls apart
out of it was just an Abrupt violent
episode that she has how did you react
hello I'm gonna I I don't know if you
guys can hear this audio but
you please put the pillowcase back onto
the pillow I won't perform for your
camera so what he wanted to do hold on
hold on wait you just said that you just
said that you've been filming stuff for
Bobby and that whenever the camera comes
on he just each man is just perfect he
just turns on and he literally in the
video is like please don't tell me I
don't want to perform for your camera
that's what he said that's exactly what
out of nowhere
out of did she how did you react
I won't perform for your camera so what
he wanted to do was
um pin me down and tickle me see so we
were filming okay I'm not asking you to
I'm asking for you to put the pillow
back in the cage
is that what you want okay I'm gonna
fast forward lay it out Bobby's [ __ ]
up okay fun times play it out we'll cut
it out if we grabs my wrist see he said
he grab something I don't think they're
messed up
laughter
okay oh
he's pinning me down okay
yeah
pins my leg down okay
okay
oh my God she loves it he's an awful
human
yeah let me see that just his mouth this
is the second it oh my god look look
no blood coming out of your tongue
he was also [ __ ] high as [ __ ] in this
too yeah he was [ __ ] up wow these
people are a mess dude they are a
[ __ ] mess
she's evil yeah she's straight up evil
person
um I don't know Bobby Lee looks like he
knows how to party if you ask me